lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
pensar en cuánto debemos utilizar un
estadístico tep y cuando un estadístico
zeta
al hacer una prueba de significancia hay
dos escenarios principales cuando
pensamos en una clase introductoria de
estadística
el primero es trabajar con proporciones
y el segundo es trabajar con medias en
el primer caso en el caso de las
proporciones cuando estamos haciendo una
prueba de significancia tenemos unas
siete hipótesis nula que usualmente nos
dicen que la proporción de una población
es igual a un cierto valor
llamémosle p subíndice 1
y seguramente tendrás una hipótesis
alternativa que nos dice que la
proporción de una población puede ser
mayor que ese valor peso 21 o menor que
ese valor peso vince 1 es decir no es
igual a ese mismo valor p subíndice 1
con esto lo que hacemos en la prueba de
significancia es tomar una muestra de la
población de tamaño n y tenemos que
estar seguros de que es válido hacer la
inferencia recuerdan que ya hemos
hablado de las condiciones necesarias
para hacer la inferencia en otros vídeos
y de esta muestra calcularemos la
proporción muestral y de esta proporción
calcularemos el valor p recuerda que el
valor p es la probabilidad de obtener
una proporción de la muestra al menos en
este extremo y si esta probabilidad es
menor que un umbral preestablecido
entonces
rechazaremos la hipótesis nula y
sugeriremos la alternativa
y la forma de obtener ese valor p es
encontrando un valor z asociado para
esta proporción muestral para esta
persona pero para calcular ese valor z
tenemos que calcular cuántas
desviaciones estándar muestrales estamos
de la media y recuerda la media de la
distribución muestral de proporciones
será la proporción poblacional así que
aquí tenemos este estadístico muestral
esta proporción muestral y tomaremos la
diferencia entre esto y la proporción
supuesta recuerda cuando hacemos pruebas
de significancia intentamos calcular la
probabilidad suponiendo que es cierta la
hipótesis nula por esta razón pongo peso
brindis 30 esta es la proporción de la
población que suponemos en la hipótesis
nula y a la diferencia de estos dos de
la proporción muestral y la proporción
supuesta vamos a dividirla entre el
error estándar del estadístico que
simplemente es la desviación estándar de
la distribución muestral de las
proporciones
y todo esto funciona muy bien cuando
trabajamos con proporciones porque en
las proporciones puedo averiguar este
valor esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de la proporción poblacional supuesta
por uno menos la proporción poblacional
supuesta y todo eso entre n
y después usaremos este estadístico z
para encontrar el valor p en este caso
observaremos ambas colas de la
distribución porque nos interesa saber
qué tan lejos estamos por encima o por
debajo de la proporción poblacional
supuesta esto en el primer caso en el
segundo caso en el caso de las medias
trabajamos con algo similar también
tenemos unas siete hipótesis nula que
nos dice que la media de la población es
igual a un cierto valor
llamémosle muy 1 y seguramente tendrás
una hipótesis alternativa que nos dicen
que la media de una población no es
igual a ese mismo valor y vamos a hacer
algo muy simple vamos a tomar la
población y vamos a sacar una muestra de
tamaño n y ahora en lugar de calcular la
proporción muestral calcularemos la
media de la muestra de hecho puedes
calcular otras cosas como son la
desviación estándar de la muestra
etcétera pero ahora tenemos una
dificultad
anteriormente trabajábamos con un
estadístico z podríamos decir que es
estadístico z en esta ocasión sería la
media de la muestra menos la media de la
población que supusimos en la hipótesis
nula y es por eso que le pongo un
subíndice 0 recuerda es lo que asumimos
en la hipótesis nula y esto entre el
error estándar de la media que es otra
forma de decir la desviación estándar de
la distribución muestral de la media
muestral el problema es que esta
desviación estándar no es nada sencilla
de calcular para encontrarla es
necesario encontrar a la desviación
estándar de la población dividida entre
la raíz cuadrada de n sabemos el valor
de n si hacemos una muestra de tamaño n
sabemos n y su raíz cuadrada pero no
sabemos cuál es la desviación estándar
de la población por esta razón lo que
hacemos es estimar esta desviación
estándar muestral
y para eso tomamos la diferencia de la
media de la muestra menos la media de la
población que supusimos en la hipótesis
nula y lo vamos a dividir entre el
estimado de la desviación estándar que
será nuestra desviación estándar de la
muestra entre la raíz cuadrada de n
y dado que esto es un estimado entonces
en lugar de decir que todo un conjunto
es un estimado del estadístico z
llamaremos a esto un estadístico
y como veremos al tomar este estadístico
temp
en una tabla tema esto nos dará una idea
más cercana de la probabilidad que
buscamos en fin espero que todo esto te
ayuda a entender cuándo usar cada
estadístico por ahora es todo nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo